so this has been a big question is - how
did vocal learning circuits evolve to
answer that question we also need to
understand what are these vocal learning
circuits well only a few species have
them us humans these songbirds a few
others I'll tell you about in a minute
and they all have a similar brain
pathway that we and others discovered in
our fore brain that controls the muscles
that produces sound and what's
interesting is in all the species that
we discovered this vocal learning
pathway it's embedded in another pathway
that all species have learning how to
control our movements and wings for
flying learning how to walk and so forth
so this led to a new theory called the
motor theory of vocal learning origin
where we think that the speech vocal
learning circuits in our brain and these
birds evolved by duplicating the pathway
that controls other body parts and now
hooking it up to the voice instead of
learning how to walk learning how to
talk so basically the vocal learning
circuit is a motor learning circuit and
in terms of who has it and why self to
species well like I said us humans but
there are a few other mammals elephants
dolphins and whales well they call
pinnipeds those of like seals and
walruses and also of bats in the
ultrasonic range that we can't hear and
there are only three groups of birds
these songbirds like the zebra finch
hummingbirds and parrots you just heard
along to learn a song and what that guy
is trying to do is to sing to the
females to say my song sounds sexy be
with me and we think that's one of the
things that selecting for vocal learning
but why so few species well I think that
predators are selecting against it if
you evolve this thing to keep attention
to the opposite sex
you're also keeping attention to the
Predators out there
and you could be eaten but the ones like
us like humans and dolphins whales the
top predators can evade these other ones
the common ancestor of these birds and
songbirds and parrots was a apex
predator so that's one theory there are
many other theories it's a why so few
species have it may be the ones that
have the bigger brains
songbirds have a bigger brain than other
species humans have a bigger brain than
other mammal species another is
something about the social interaction
of the species creates this environment
for the genetic mechanisms to cause a
brain circuit to evolve more social
complex behaviors but I like the
predator Hut and the sexual selection
hypothesis is the best it makes more
sense of what we're seeing like these
guys seem to attract the female but
there is one more new theory that we've
come up with that explains both of these
questions about where the circuits for
VOC Lauren came from and why so few
species we call it the Continuum
Hypothesis bacopa learning and the
discovery for that came from studying
mice we found that mice actually have a
rudimentary brain circuit that we find
in humans for speech in Saunders for
song and they have some rudimentary
abilities to change their songs that the
females like and so what we think could
be happening is that maybe it's not a
black a white world the haves and the
have-nots but it's a continuum like
turning up the dial or turning down the
dial to make the behavior more complex
or less complex and in humans we're at
this end of the continuum mice and some
other species frogs at this end and
other species in between so we're
testing this continuum hypothesis and
how we're testing it well if mice are
somewhere in the middle or even yeah a
little bit at the other end of the
continuum can we take the human genes
put it in a mouse brain in the mouse
cells in the mouse genome and push that
Mouse to dial up the dial along that
continuum and to get it to be more like
a song
even us